[Music]
[Applause]
Justin Herbert said to join us part of
the goal to make homes better for all
Lowe's is giving back to the communities
it serves through Lowe's Home towns the
company's largest ever Community IMPACT
program and uh Justin Herbert the
Chargers quarterback joining us on the
program good morning Justin what's the
setup going to be for Super Bowl Sunday
for you
um I'll just be with my fan my family
and friends probably just watching the
game
um you know I haven't watched too much
of the playoffs but uh you know it'll
always be a good game between those guys
how tough is it to not watch or to watch
a game
um you know as an NFL player you want to
be in those games you want to be able to
play deep into the playoffs and
unfortunately it didn't go our way this
year
um but we know that we've we've got the
guys and we just have to keep putting in
the hard work this off season
um so looking forward to the opportunity
this year okay but let's say a relative
says Justin why aren't you playing in
the Super Bowl
what are you going to say at the party
I'll just probably explain you know what
what went down uh unfortunately we
didn't make it um you know these two
teams worked really hard to be no no no
you come out of the party is what you do
Justin you say that's a stupid question
come on can't you see I'm hurt here I'm
I'm not playing in the game
that's what you need to say
yeah I'll be I'll make sure to do that
okay all right uh you played the Chiefs
twice if Jalen hurts called and said all
right help me out here
what do I do what do I not do what would
you say
yeah I would say be ready for pressure
you know they've done a great job of
disrupting the passer uh they'll bring
different looks
um you know they've got some really
impressive guys on the front seven that
are able to get after the passer and so
they're going to be able to do a bunch
of different coverages they're gonna
they're gonna Blitz a bunch of different
guys
um and so you just have to be ready for
all those different protections okay you
go to the line of scrimmage the first
person you look for is who
uh you got to be aware of where Chris
Jones is um especially where he lines up
they're able to get him around so well
as big as he is he's not hard to find
though
exactly exactly yeah he's the biggest
guy out on the field uh probably the
most athletic so uh definitely tough to
watch okay you look back on how many
times did he sack you during the season
um I can't remember the exact number I
think uh one or twice okay once or twice
okay did he land on you
no no
that's a big guy though and you know
what's weird though Justin I I was
talking to uh uh Marcus Spears and I he
said you know everybody thinks about
Aaron Donald and they forget about Chris
Jones or everybody thinks about Bosa and
uh even Hassan Reddick but Chris Jones
just quietly goes about disrupting a
game
yeah and I think one of the best things
that he does is he's able to line up and
de-tackle the end they move him around
and and that makes it so tough on the
offense of of knowing where he is being
able to slide the protection to him but
he's so disruptive and he's done such a
great job for so many years Kurt Warner
has said before he loved when he was
blitzed because then he sort of knew
where the mismatch was
does that follow what you uh your
philosophy
yeah I totally understand what he's
saying you know when they bring more
guys into pressure uh there are less
guys in coverage and so you got better
one-on-one matchups uh you might have
more routes open
um and so just being able to have things
downfield I think is is super helpful
for an offense what was tough for losing
Mike Williams or Rashawn Slater
oh uh those are two really fantastic
players uh losing both is is never fun
or losing one is never fun either
um you know there are two huge pieces of
our offense
um and very tough to replace no you
didn't answer the question come on
um this is I don't know about the radio
show I mean you know you know the rules
here
you know the rules
um
you know they they're they're two of the
best to do it I don't know if I can pick
one over the other no you pick your left
you pick your tackle you you know
because if you can't throw the ball it
doesn't matter who you're throwing the
ball to Mike Williams understands that
yeah I mean that's that's one way of
looking at it sounds very important
I'm Chris Jones right now I'm putting
some pressure on
yeah I know you've done a good job okay
do you look back
it's an ends when do you look at the
tape for this uh past year
uh we we've watched all the games and
watched the Jacksonville game
um and you know that's something that
we'll continue to watch
um the next couple of months
um but uh now it's it's a new offense
that we're going to be able to learn and
kind of get into that so there's gonna
be a lot to do this off season okay what
is the new offense going to be like how
is it different from last this past
season
um you know that's that's one of those
questions that we have to address in the
next couple of weeks um you know Kellen
was recently hired and we'll get going
here pretty soon I know he's super busy
figuring out
um everything that's going on with
coming to a new team and establishing
you know his presence here but uh really
excited to be able to work with him and
get to know all about what he does do
you care who wins on Sunday
um I'm just hoping for a good game
um you know I think there are two really
really good football teams I got a lot
of respect for both teams played the
Eagles last year uh we know how good
they are and how good that defense and
offense is so
um just looking for a good game yeah but
do you want somebody from your own
division to win
um as a competitor no but uh you know
it's not really my place to root for one
team over the other yeah but I I can't
root for the Chiefs if I'm in their
division
yeah I mean we got a lot of respect for
them you know they're a really good
football team
um you know Jalen and Patrick they're
both really good quarterbacks so it'll
be fun to watch I'm trying to get you
off your spot you know what you're you
know you're just giving me these uh
answers that somebody you know you're
shaking me off is what you're doing
right now
you played baseball right
yeah a little bit I couldn't hit those
100 mile an hour fastballs though were
you any good
um I used to throw the ball really hard
but that's all that's about all I had
was fastballs um so I didn't have any
off-speed pitches yeah they sit on those
fastballs after a while and and they can
catch up to those things how fast could
you throw
um I don't know I I never really got the
um you know the actual number I I
thought I threw pretty hard but I guess
High School is one thing so uh never
made it past there so I think that tells
you all you need to know well if you
throw 90 in high school that's like you
know throwing 95 or so in in the majors
so you probably threw 90 miles an hour
I'd like to think I got up there I don't
know if I can actually say that I did or
not um it felt like it did I threw up I
threw pretty hard but about all I had we
have uh Trevor Lawrence on later today
if we had a uh hair off who do you think
would win
I think he'd win oh really
wow okay uh I I mean I had Trevor's a
one seed I had he was a two seed though
you got to let it go a little bit more
are you cleaning up here
I just don't put a whole lot of effort
into it
um you know I I think that it's more so
just a
you know I wake up go to work and see
what happens but uh you know I think
Trevor he's that's a respectful you know
head of hair
he he flips his hair around a little bit
like it it's really important to him
yeah I mean it's impressive
going with Lowe's the hometown projects
yeah well uh so this past year we have
actually worked on the Kid City
Breezeway project which turned an unused
area into a beautiful outdoor space for
an after-school program and Lowe's home
team is a five-year 100 million dollar
investment buy lows in the community it
serves
um so it's been an honor to be a part of
it awesome well great to talk to you
hope you have a great off-season the
folks from Traeger are here and uh they
said to say hello Chad said to say hello
love those guys thank you very much keep
the mustache okay
I'll do my best yeah
Justin
we'll see you thank you Justin Herbert
by the way now through February 20th
community members can go to lowes.com
hometowns to nominate their Hometown
projects